pièce séparée largeur de votre bassin
Florence largeur du bassin
[Musique]
voilà
ensemble placez votre pied droit à
l'intérieur de votre cuisse gauche
compressez le talon à l'intérieur de
votre adducteur l'Inter de votre cuisse
votre posture est encré concentration
est à tous tes preuves vous êtes
totalement inébranlable
sentez-vous léger alignez cherchez
vraiment à sentir cette légèreté cet
ancrage dans votre corps respirez très
profondément attrapez derrière vos
genoux et rouler doucement pour venir
avec moi dans la posture de la charrue
les genoux fléchis les pierres relâchent
en arrière trouver une posture dans
laquelle vous êtes confortable une
respiration profonde